now that we've registered our weather
provider in the android manifest it's
time to begin coding our weather
provider
this is the final and most involved step
in implementing our content provider
we'll be filling out these core content
provider functions
except for oncreate which we've already
done for you
we've added an instance variable for our
database helper
we initialize this in our oncreate
function we will use this database
helper in most of the content provider
methods the first of the content
provider methods that we will look at is
get type
implementing a functional version of get
type isn't strictly necessary for our
application
but it's a nice way to review what your
eyes were planning to handle we've
partially filled out the get type
function for you we use the uri matcher
we built earlier to match the given uri
against the expressions we've compiled
in
for each match we return the types that
we've defined in the weather contract
remember that the key information this
conveys is whether the content uri will
be returning a database cursor
containing a single record type item or
multiple records type directory
content providers can also be used to
return other kinds of data than just
database cursors
for example if we wanted the content
provider to return jpeg images for a
content uri
we would have this function return the
standard mime type image slash jpeg
let's uncomment the test get type test
from within test provider
this will get us ready for the next
coding exercise